foreign  [Music]  how did you write Wuthering Heights  Shall We Begin  miss Emily Bronte you're off to become a  wonderful teacher you know I don't like  to meet new people  [Music]  what do you want to do do you think I  could be a writer  I have lots of stories  Mr Leighton will be tutoring you in  French  he speaks with such poetry any man can  speak which I want to know is can he  actually do do what  it's supposed to be an artist so be an  artist what is that I wrote it  freedom and thought freedom and thought  come on  I have often struggled to understand you  your poetry  [Music]  not bring shame on this house Emily  did you write please it's an ugly book  there's something ungodly in your  writing I feel it when we're together  you know if they call you the strange  one  everyone's strange if you look at them  for long enough  [Music]  foreign  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign